aujourd'hui moins d'un français sur 12
s'est exprimé c'est le principal
enseignement de ce premier tour le
niveau d'abstention jamais vu depuis
1958 témoignent de la persistance des
fractures de la société française s'est
fracturé s'était exprimée avec force au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle elles ne sont ni oublié
ni effacés encore moins de dépasser ce
soir au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle près d'un français sur
deux était prêt à choisir des solutions
radicales au second tour 16 millions de
français par l'abstention des gens et
par le vote blanc ont refusé de se
prononcer entre emmanuel macron et le
front national
l'abstention s'est amplifiée à l'état
extrêmement préoccupante
de nombreux facteurs ont certainement
joué une campagne présidentielle très
longue avec de multiples rebondissements
la volonté aussi pour certains
d'enjamber ce scrutin législatif en
oubliant fondamentalement les enjeux
tout cela peut être dissuadé un peu plus
encore les électeurs de se déplacer
le deuxième enseignement est que si la
coalition en marche modem vire en tête
au premier tour le second tour opposera
quant à lui dans la plupart des
circonscriptions un candidat de la
droite et du centre
un candidat on marche le débat est
indispensable les français aspirent à la
clarté clarté des convictions clarté du
débat clarté sur les grands choix pour
notre pays il reste donc une semaine
pour mettre en lumière les différences
qui existent entre nos candidats et
sedan marche dans un débat projet contre
projet ouvert profondément républicain
est naturellement respectueux des uns et
des autres les français doivent savoir
qu'en marche voeux un choc fiscal d'un
niveau équivalent à celui de françois
hollande a imposé aux classes moyennes
la hausse annoncée d'un 7 points de la
csg soit plus de 20 % de cet impôt va
toucher puissamment les retraités les
fonctionnaires les artisans les
commerçants les agriculteurs les
indépendants et les épargnants nous ne
pouvons plus accepter de hausses
d'impôts aussi spectaculaire qui menace
d'étouffer notre économie nous voulons
sortir du carcan des 35 heures en marche
propose le statu quo nous avons entendu
le cri de la ruralité qui s'est exprimé
lors de la pré
en ciel nous n'oublions pas que la
france est sur deux vit dans une commune
de moins de 10000 habitants
nous demandons un moratoire sur la
fermeture des services publics en milieu
rural et nous demandons car un euro
investi pour la ville correspondent un
euro investi dans la ruralité
nous portons des valeurs de liberté de
responsabilité
nous voulons réarmer de puissamment
l'état face au terrorisme
restaurer son autorité et tourner le dos
au laxisme pénale des exemples parmi
tant d'autres de nos différences
nombreuses avec en marche parce que nous
portons un projet de rassemblement de
tous les français nous disons également
à tous ceux qui se sont abstenus ou qui
ont un vrai choix différent au premier
tour à ceux qui ont exprimé un vote de
colère à votre bic aspirations que notre
pays attend des pouvoirs équilibrés et
non concentré dans un seul et même parti
les projections en sièges annoncé
montrent qu'un sursaut est indispensable
pour le second tour de ces élections
législatives
il est en effet indispensable pour
porter un maximum de candidats d'union
de la droite et du centre à l'assemblée
nationale
il est indispensable également car c'est
bien dimanche prochain dans une semaine
que les gros choix pour le pays vont se
décider
la mobilisation de tous est impérative
afin d'éclairer le plus et le mieux
possible les français pour les cinq
années à venir